no estar después saber la verdad es que
ha sido digamos una jornada muy
tranquila tanto aquí en la capital
francesa como en realidad en todo el
país no se han presentado ni se ha
sabido de incidentes con la entrada en
vigor de este pase ya de vacunación ha
sido digamos que bueno hay 53 millones
de personas que ya están vacunadas así
que saben cómo es este día a día pero
son quizás esos 4 millones y medio de
franceses que todavía no se han vacunado
los que van a comenzar a ver las
dificultades que van a tener en su vida
diaria de no poder ir a un café no
pueden ir a un restaurante de no poder
viajar en un bus en un tren en un avión
porque para todo esto necesitan estar
completamente vacunados el gobierno ha
querido ser flexible y de hecho ha
indicado que de aquí al próximo 15 de
febrero las personas que pues reciban la
primera dosis de la vacuna podrán tener
un pase de vacunación temporal
presentando además junto con este pues
un test negativo para poder entrar a
todos estos establecimientos de ocio
entre otros natalia ha incrementado la
tasa de vacunación previo a la entrada
en vigor de esta medida
bueno si lo digamos que los días
anteriores cuando se supo que se estaba
discutiendo todo este proyecto de ley en
la asamblea nacional según cifras
entregadas por el gobierno nacional más
de un millón de franceses corrieron a
hacerse vacunar pero en estos días pues
digamos que ese número de vacunas
diarias no pasan de los 26.000 como les
decía hay 53 millones de personas que
están vacunados eso representa grosso
modelo 80% de la población francesa y en
estos días pues habrá que esperar
también poco a poco cuando las personas
se den cuenta de las trabas que
significa no estar vacunado que quizás
bueno esta política pública pues se
tenga su efecto que es finalmente
presionar a estas personas para que
finalmente se vacuna